all right we had a bunch of interesting
stuff happen over the weekend i want to
start with a rally that took place in
coleman alabama this is a relevant rally
for two or three different reasons
number one this is sort of the start of
the 2022
election it's it seems to be getting
going this early mo brooks is running in
alabama donald trump flew in it was an
all-day rally and donald trump showing
up there in the midst of bad weather and
chaos and lies and delusions in support
of mo brooks also relevant was this
rally because of all the people who of
course delusionally believed that donald
trump was going to be reinstated as
president during august this is likely
to be donald trump's last public
appearance in august unless some other
rally gets scheduled for this last week
or ten days uh eight days that's left of
august and there was the belief among
some and
i mean obviously this is ridiculous but
there was the belief among some that at
this rally donald trump was going to be
reinstated as president one such reason
why some believe that was that ceo of my
pillow mike lindell who i interviewed a
couple weeks ago was at this rally and
why that would make anyone think there's
going to be a reinstatement like it none
of it makes sense i'm telling you the
reasons why
people who don't know anything thought
maybe trump would be reinstated i'll cut
to the chase he was not but let's get
into some of these clips from this rally
it's a very
repetitive speech donald trump was very
confused and dishonest and we're going
to look at a number of different moments
but the most notable moment
and we're going to dive into this a
little bit later
is that donald trump was booed by his
own sycophantic followers when he
casually said hey guys the vaccine is
good and trump immediately having to
backtrack and say no it's okay it's okay
you've got your freedoms take a listen
to this three days less than nine months
and it's great and you know what i
believe totally in your freedoms i do
agree you gotta do what you have to do
but
i recommend taking the vaccines i did it
it's good take the vaccines but
you got no that's okay that's all right
and then the jeering starts freedoms
but i happen to take the vaccine
if it doesn't work you'll be the first
to know okay
that is really something i mean that is
sort of like when you train
a protection dog
to be so aggressive
that it even starts being dangerous to
the owner the owner has to get rid of
the dog because the dog meant to protect
him is too it's too aggressive it's too
dangerous
i think this is the first time that a
rally crowd of trumps
actually booed him i think they boo when
he gets them to boost someone else when
he says something about hillary or biden
or whatever
but i can't remember another time where
they actually booed donald trump a lot
of the stuff during the rally was kind
of the the typical stuff uh donald trump
uh claiming that the election was stolen
and that very soon you're going to see
the evidence coming out we've been
waiting for months i mean will any of us
still be alive when that evidence comes
out take a listen
one of the first acts that biden did
after mitch mcconnell said we must get
back to work we have to get our country
going we have to approve him as the
president
even though the evidence was staggering
you'll see the evidence starting to come
out it's already come out far beyond
what we need by the way far far far
beyond what we need and yet it hasn't
seemed to work
to put trump back in the office because
this is all a grift we have to get back
to our country and running our country
mitch mcconnell and the first thing that
biden did was sign 17 of the worst
executive orders in the history of our
country those executive orders actually
were pretty good in that they undid a
lot of the damage that donald trump did
trump then you know as usual on covid he
just seems confused he weighed in on the
delta variant and he talked about how
he's shaking hands with everybody and
hopefully it doesn't cause an outbreak
you know he doesn't know he didn't stop
the virus you know they say oh he gets
wonderful marxism get good marks he's
done a terrible job including on
vaccinations including on everything
else and now the virus is back
the virus is back i'm shaking hands with
everybody backstage i say well i don't
know this is a good thing or bad
you'll read about it in three or four
days maybe hopefully not
so he seems to acknowledge that
sometimes when he does these big events
and he's hanging out with people and
shaking hands
it causes spread and we i mean listen we
know it happened herman cain at least in
theory
got sick at a trump rally and
subsequently died we don't know that for
sure but the timing of it certainly
suggests that just always very confused
at a certain point during this event
trump shifted over into what we might
call foreign policy now he you might
hear this and say david that's not
really foreign policy what i mean is he
mentioned foreign countries
and when it comes to trump that's as
close to foreign policy as we're ever
going to get listen to this can't have
weakness in the white house they have to
respect your president when i was
president
we only had strength remember the 59
shots we took at syria
now remember those 59 shots at syria
that's the bombing of the runway
that he let russia know about ahead of
time which was cleared
and then reopened within 24 hours that's
the and i'm i'm not an advocate of
bombing i'm just saying even trump
projecting strength on that it was
pretty pathetic
59 missiles every single one of them hit
their target from 700 miles away
and i was sitting with president xi of
china you remember having
chocolate cake at mar-a-lago was
wonderful keck
and when i said to him what we had just
done the missiles were launched he
looked at me and he goes
repeat
i didn't know he spoke english actually
he said repeat i said what did you just
say repeat
so he spoke a little more english than i
thought because he never said hello but
he said repeat so of course we don't
know whether trump is saying she said
repeat the bombing or repeat what you
said it's a completely incoherent story
as are most of these and then speaking
of foreign policy maybe one of the
strangest moments of the speech donald
trump claimed that a five-year-old was
advising him on military issues that's
weird but
i asked the child
so what would you do after describing
would you leave the military until
everything's out including the civilians
and
all of that incredible military
equipment
or would you have the military go out
first
sir i'd leave the military in
he was five
he said i'd leave the military in
get everything out first i said thank
you very much but they didn't want me
all right so there it is a five-year-old
kid knew exactly what it is that trump
should be doing uh there it is and then
um maybe the most sort of despicable
moments were when donald trump started
praising and shouting out complete and
total lunatics like marjorie taylor
greene who we'll talk about a little bit
later
and later mike pillow also known as mike
lindell let's listen first to him
talking about how great marjorie taylor
green is one of my favorite people oh
she's so smart
i hope she's around i hope she's around
she is an incredible woman
she's a brilliant woman doesn't get
credit for it but we all know about that
stuff
marjorie taylor green
where is she
can you imagine
she's great
she is great she's a warrior
she's a warrior everything i said about
georgia is true audrey right yeah
and that's really what it's about she
placates trump
when it comes to his bogus
baseless exhausting tired claims that
actually he won georgia and not joe
biden and then trump talking about mike
pillow my pillow ceo mike lindell he
likes him too a patriot a wonderful man
by the way a patriot man who puts his
guts into everything
a man that they don't treat properly
he's smart he loves his country so much
he's willing to die for this country i
watched him over the last week
at his symposium which was really
amazing some of the people
do we really believe trump watched that
lunatic symposium maybe he did i don't
know
we're incredible incredible people
mike lindell mike
and the crowd loves it
yeah
so anyway another completely unhinged
rally you know the weird thing we we
stream this live the weird thing about
trump rallies is that the crowd is so
sycophantic i mean at this point they
drive out to the middle of nowhere it's
just a field in alabama thunderstorms
they're there all day waiting for trump
trump's an hour plus late as always
and they just they just love the guy
they love him love him love him and yet
number one he mentions the vaccine and
they boo him and we're going to dig into
that more because i think that's a big
that's a big thing
but also
they they very quickly check out and
seem bored at these events it's this
huge huge build up maybe it's because
they're exhausted by the time trump
actually comes out as soon as trump
comes out to speak they very quickly
lose energy and you see people on their
phones often you see couples talking to
each other and checking the time you can
tell they're talking about how long are
we really going to stay this is sort of
going nowhere it's almost castro like
he's not going six hours but sometimes
going two hours talking about nothing
it's a very weird thing which shouldn't
surprise us because after all these are
the people we'd expect to see at these
events
i've struggled falling asleep at night
and realized part of it could be because
of the blue light coming from my phone
and computer screens and peer-reviewed
studies have shown that blue light can
suppress the hormone melatonin which can
make it difficult to fall asleep blue
light can disturb your circadian rhythms
but it hasn't been an issue for me since
i discovered blue blocks glasses which
filter out that blue light they're one
of our sponsors a lot of other companies
are mass producing supposed blue light
glasses and factories with no actual
quality standards blue blocks glasses
are made in actual optics labs at their
headquarters in australia they have over
40 stylish frames a prescription version
non-prescription even reading glasses
and for every pair of glasses that blue
blocks sells they give a pair of reading
glasses to someone in need you'll get
twenty percent off when you go to blue
blocks dot com slash pacman the link is
right underneath this video and there's
free shipping worldwide on orders over a
hundred and fifteen dollars